kyondra now predicts that denise is done
and we won't see her at the Reunion do
you think that's the case no I think
she'll be at the Reunion and I think
yeah I mean I've seen some of the press
she's done I definitely think she'll be
there so there's still room for Denise
in this group moving forward I think
she'll be heavily in house quarantine
life Teddy well currently I'm in my
bedroom my kids are virtually learning
right now I mean it's a it's a little
bit of chaos but you know it comes and
goes is this the new confessional
backdrop we'd be seeing this on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills this is my
bed that I now am forced to make every
single day because of these zoom calls
and confessionals yes you guys are
having to film your interviews for their
show like this right now instead of
lighting hair makeup all the things we
normally say yeah I mean you should see
how I'm like tried to rig like one light
that sits here that it's probably not
even hitting me in the right direction
but I have no one to tell me different
everyone's like did you get them bounce
which I guess it's like a light that
shines up on you but it's it's up here
so I know it does nothing so isn't what
it is we're just figuring it out and you
have a newborn baby at home too
yeah that's definitely I mean she has a
little bit of colic so she's definitely
in the stage where she wants to be held
if she's in the baby bjorn and we're
carrying her around so we are in the
thick of it you seem to be handling it
quite well done it really depends on the
day you know I think kind of everybody
I've talked to though have said the same
thing like I have really good days and
then I have days where I feel super
emotional or like you know because
especially for a control freak like me
not knowing what's happening is can be
challenging and the unknowns there's so
much uncertainty well one thing we know
that is consistent is every Wednesday
you will get the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills season ten one thing we
know how are you feeling about the
season uh you know I'm really just
trying to take it same thing one day at
a time you know like it's there there's
so much fun this season but I think
because so many of us know each other so
much more now and we've like stripped
down some of the layers it's less
surface like I know challenging things
are coming when it comes to me and when
it comes to everybody else
yeah Beverly Hills I feel like does get
a bad rap of being like a slow burn and
maybe a little surface sometimes but I
noticed that right out of the gate in
the premiere it was almost like the
producer of the editors knew like we
have to acknowledge stuff that was
criticized last year it's like the REITs
going to talk about our lawsuit we're
gonna see friction between Kyle and
Mauricio like we're gonna see all these
things that the fans have been like why
don't we see this let me see that it's
happening this year I think everything's
completely stripped down this year and I
think you know there will be sort of
stuff that will really make people laugh
and there'll be some stuff that make
people cringe it's gonna be all the
emotions I know for me
well that final two minutes of the
premiere left people with a lot of
emotion chilling I told you it was gonna
be chilling I know you warned me but I
wasn't ready I am NOT doing this you
guys we've got I'm stopped bravo Bravo
Team Bravo
I'm out I'm not
doing what was going through your mind
when you were in the moment of that
bravo Bravo Bravo CD because that's
something we've never seen on housewives
well we've never I had never seen that
you know like there I think Kyle talked
about it on like Bravo TVs like live
feed
so season 1 there was a little like joke
that we would have the original
housewives and myself try to touch up so
we don't look horrible and if the
cameras come back up and we don't want
them to film us yet we would joke and
say you know Oh robble robble robble hi
Andy Cohen they wouldn't use the footage
because you can't because they don't
acknowledge that we're on a show you
know and it was like a joke but I had
never seen or heard about it and
somebody like wanting to not something
not to be used that's like seriously
going on in our group I'd like to say
that was the only time that happened
this season but it wasn't Denis tweeted
at you and it's I haven't here because
it the phrasing didn't make total sense
to me but she said you were that someone
that told me Kyle Richards about it I
was like Denis writing me or cos amigos
I'm confused
well I don't get are you saying I told
you about I have never said bravo Bravo
Bravo and I can assure you if I had they
would use it it's not like I'm like
living it up in the like happy life of
everyone loving me every time so I you
know we had all heard stories about how
they wanted to do it to touch up their
lip gloss but I don't I don't know what
that tweet meant so we're all still
confused I mean obviously I would have
written something sassy back if I
understood but it's from looking at that
flash ahead of all that montage it seems
like there was stuff going down with
Denis before the brandy revelation habit
Oh
I mean obviously I mean a lot of things
were going down with Denis before brandy
alleged
and and that's really the issue what
happened was brandy I mean that's just
like what they've played out in the
press but that's not what any of us or
myself had any kind of you know
situation with Denise about so I know we
have to wait and see what those issues
are and watch a play out but can give me
a hint of what that is like what were
the issues here's the thing I I can't
really say too much but what I can say
is when you sign up to do the show
you show the good the bad and the ugly
and if your primary focus on being on
the show is what the audience is gonna
think about you and not what us what
each one of your friends is feeling then
it always ends up backfiring because
you're trying to control a situation
that can't be controlled and then the
people that are living it with you can
feel it does that make sense without
giving too much away that makes sense
what did we safe to say that Denise came
into her second season operating a
little differently than she did her
first season with this group I think she
saw what people like to see in her and
then tried to double down on it and
maybe it didn't maybe a backfire yeah
maybe
look it's okay you think all of us can
be jerks from time to time all of us can
say things that we're gonna regret I can
be super uptight I can be judgy I can be
you know whatever but I also have a
loving family and I have a business that
I love and I'm a good friend so like
there's parts of every single one of us
and if you're only trying to show one
heart and then you're okay with kind of
putting it off on other people it just
doesn't work out so from looking at all
those scenes it looks like the walk off
moment happens before the allegation
comes up yeah yeah there's something big
before that that we're gonna get into
yes sir I mean I think you know I think
it's so annoying when too much plays out
in the press because you know that
that's that person's intention to kind
of get the audience to see whatever it
is that they want to see prior to
watching the show and that's like that
takes you know part of what people are
watching the show for out of it you know
and so I think by both parties doing
that and it made it harder because now
everybody's going into the show assuming
it's one thing when really it's not well
that could be it'll be exciting I guess
for the audience because that means
there's a lot of surprises in store it's
not gonna be like last year we had kind
of seen the whole story play out like we
kind of always happily this is not the
story I mean that's the that's juicy and
people are interested in it because it's
you know but there's definitely more
that involves all of us that affects
everybody differently I mean there's
they're doing on their own time really
has nothing to do with me
in that premiere hyaline Rena predicts
that Denise is done and we won't see her
at the Reunion do you think that's the
case no I think she'll be at the Reunion
and I think yeah I mean I've seen some
of the press she's done I definitely
think she'll be there
she seems I mean that look at the end of
the episode she seems like she might be
ready to fight back I think that she has
done this for a lot of years whether
she's on Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills or not okay
so there's still room for Denise in this
group moving forward you think I think
she'll be up in the Union alright a
couple other things we see in the
trailer I want to get your reaction to
jury saying judge you was he was a
pregnant woman what was that about
who knows to read loves to come at me
it's like her favorite thing ever and
the crazy thing is to read and I can
laugh and have fun together but like the
second we disagree on something it's
like BAM and you see the like she is
down to call me names whenever she gets
a shot she just communicates very
differently than I do and sometimes it
takes her a little bit of time to get to
a point and then by the time she does
get to the point you're already kind of
irritated and then you're
nice now I'm pissed and irritated and
it's 45 minutes later and then Sutton
just flat-out tells you you're boring to
your face Teddy you with a little boring
are we supposed to be honest or not I
know and you know what there's more that
she says that actually really sets me
off but I was like Sutton come on do
your research somewhere other than
Twitter like maybe try talking to me
from more than 10 seconds and not about
couture and then let's see where we go
do you think Sutton came and having like
looked everybody up and had a read on
everyone before because she was in the
premiere her confessional was kind of
like Viper tongues toward everybody oh
she came in hot it's bending fenty no
fenty Rihanna Fenty if a celebrity has
done a collaboration I could care less
she came in hot and definitely like
there was more things that happened in
New York like I was like whoa like she
said some kind of outlandish things that
I was like dang and so maybe I was
boring to her cuz I wasn't speaking to
her much oh I'm gonna keep my business
from this one outside of obviously the
Denice stuff unfolding what are you most
excited for the fans to get to
experience or finally see I truly think
that you see so much more real
relationships this year and you see
people start to really open up and talk
I feel like kind of in the past it would
be one person would share something and
then everybody else would jump in with
their opinions and so it still kind of
stayed surface now it's like we're all
kind of digging deeper getting into like
real deep-seated you know problems or
issues or things that are great in our
lives where I just don't know that it
felt that way to me before was the
dynamic of the group switching up taking
one person out of it do you think part
of the equation of everybody being able
to invest a little bit more of
themselves you know
I I can't say that for sure I can just
say that immediately from the time we
started filming this year it felt
different and it felt like everybody's
guard wasn't up is there anything you're
dreading having to relive or for the
world to see like you know you're a
Provence moment last year Teddy oh my
god Holy Mother of God
only men tonight know we're not even
chips I mean that isn't that being like
my best moment of the year uh you know I
think there's parts of yourself that you
have to see it but it's hard we're guard
'less yeah and I can be judgy and I can
be outspoken and opinionated and all
those things but I would rather be that
than be somebody who's not myself so
that everybody would think I was
agreeable and likeable all the time I
think anybody that's like oh no I've
I've never felt this way about anybody I
know I've never behaved this way come on
really do you feel like you get an
unfair wrath or like more vitriol than
some of your other cast mates because I
feel like when I go on Twitter or like
you look at the fan sites
I think it's unfairly mean to you you
know I think it was just because it was
such a big difference my first season
people were so loving and like so you
know and then with what happened my
second season I just don't think I've
I've been forgiven so I kind of have to
laugh at it and be like you know at some
point they're gonna see you know who I
am and be okay with I made a mistake and
you know some people gravitate to it and
some people are gonna hate on it I
really thought my second season like cuz
you're you're living it and I'm like
well I think it'll be okay because I was
honest I came forward with the truth
like I did and then I was like oh I was
a brutal beating a beatdown
we all have goods and back good and bad
sides and you know they can't edit us to
be a way that we're not but they can
highlight whatever
your best attributes I think Kyle has
said it if it's something you don't want
seen or you don't want to talk about
that's what's gonna be shown and talked
about oh for sure they know they know
your triggers they're like oh she's
type-a we are gonna lean into that you
an episode all about waiting for jury
you couldn't like shot me a text and
just been like I'm not coming because I
got a sitter and if you had one word for
this season what's your word I think
that this season is real the most real I
have ever felt on this show well I'm
excited to see what all of that entails
yeah it's it gets crazy I mean it's like
this and I think that as it continues on
you and I would just urge people to pay
close attention to the small details
yeah Erika said there's going to be
little things that you're gonna see pop
up all season that when these bombs drop
later in the season things will shine a
big light on things yeah oh it's like
watching it's like watching a Law &
Order episode you've really got a
spectacle well Kyle told us that you
might have been part of some detective
work you might have been bringing
information around all season long I
mean what am I not but like also I'm
sober I'm paying attention to everything
so that's what ends up happening like
people are like what happened
who said this do you remember you know
like so it looks like you know here's
the thing once you say something in this
group it's out there so if somebody
asked me Cushing what happened at that
dinner I didn't have one said Velva I'm
pregnant I know so yeah so that was your
burden to carry some days it felt like a
burden some days it felt like therapy
[Music]